you sound like a a pathologically
terrible dad
um and now you have a podcast called
dads
and it's uh it's on uh my podcast
network and
you're hosting and this is a podcast
where uh
it's not just a podcast for dads you're
talking about a lot of different issues
involving fatherhood is that correct
that is correct
uh myself and ruthie wyatt who you know
uh we co-host the show together and we
have on different guests
like yourself uh today is the first
episode that drops
and uh for everyone who listens conan
made us have him on he said if you want
this thing to work
you got to have the hot stuff right up
front yeah
so he was our first episode and yeah we
talk about
being a dad we talk about having a dad
it's not just for
dads though we also have non-dads on the
show that we interview to get
perspectives
about parenting and their relationships
with their dads and
or stepdads or yeah i had a really good
time
talking to you and like i said i did
think it was important
when you launch a podcast you have to
have the hot stuff
that's what i said um and that is
available
uh for everybody wherever you get your
podcast you can check out our interview
with conan
right now and then once a week we'll be
releasing a new
episode we have so many coming up john
leguizamo david cross
sabrina jalisce vanessa ragland the list
goes on and on
no it's uh andrew richter mm-hmm one of
our
andy we call him andy not me he makes me
call him andrew sir andrew richter
sir he caught you have to call him sir
andrew richter wow yeah i
asked i was like is that don't you have
to be knighted but he said that is
technically his first name andrew is his
middle name